[Music]
it's official RuPaul's Drag Race
all-stars 5 is coming thanks girlfriends
are you hungry from RuPaul's Drag Race
look good yes your country breakfast is
ready
and I'm serving up a new season of
all-stars 5 and with the official
announcement well even before it then
started speculating which queens may
return as I'm sure most of you know I'm
a huge fan of the show so I thought it
would be fun to pick five queens in
honor of all-stars 5 that I'd like to
see on the show starting things off we
love a redemption story and the first
Queen that I would love to see flutter
back into the competition age O'Hara
[Music]
Texas is back in the throat Season ten
Asia proved as she was a queen that
could have won but a failed finale
attempt at releasing real live
butterflies well a clipped her wings and
created a finale faux pas we will never
forget
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so what was a risk and I
appreciate that but it didn't pay off
Asia is a queen we watched have a
metamorphosis during her time on the
show and I think she's ready to fly that
was so many butterfly puns the next
queen that I would love to see maica
return two all-stars five is another
season ten Queen I do declare it's Blair
st. Claire Blair was just 22 during her
time on the show and she showcased
ridiculous promise as a performer but
she was eliminated far too soon
especially after an unforgettable honest
and real moment on the main stage my
first sexual experience I was raped at a
college party and from that I looked to
find pretty things since appearing on
the show Blair has gained a massive
following for being gorgeous she has her
makeup skills and her debut album call
me life which received critical acclaim
Blair became the first Queen from Drag
Race to have an album top of Billboard
charts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
season nine stars che cule is a queen
that everybody seems to want to return
to the workroom on all-stars five
especially since some felt shape may
have been robbed in the finale I was in
an airport the other day and this guy
goes Bigfoot guys hey che kool-aid with
Rob I mean she kind of why well you know
everyone gets you know sometimes not
winning does have its benefits
especially if you're a fan favorite like
Shea it means an all-stars call is
likely coming I think it's just I
snatched today I think you budget now
especially since appearing on the show
Shea has modeled toward the world and
released the debut EP and in my opinion
it is some of the best music to come
from any drag race stars don't see guys
mad
[Music]
all right next up is someone that I
would really love to return to all-stars
5 it's season eights kimchi I love
kimchi
I came to Chop Suey to competitions
kimchi is the first Korean American to
appear on the series and with her
mind-blowing makeup transformations
endearing personality and incredibly
artistic runway looks
kimchi easily became a favorite of the
season I don't want to be America's next
drag superstar I am America's next drag
superstar
although kimchi struggled with certain
challenges during season 8 it has now
been years since she's been on the show
which means she's likely developed into
a much more confident performer the
final and fifth queen of the five that I
would love to see on all-stars 5 is my
third queen from season 10 it was a
really great season it's the kooky miss
cracker only miss cracker could serve
model and [ __ ] on the same runway Ms
cracker in my mind is a queen who had so
many people rooting from her from the
beginning but she was her own worst
enemy I feel completely crushed right
now this is not what I came here to show
America hopefully with the boost of
confidence since appearing on this show
we would see more of MS crackers wacky
personality if she's able to get out of
her own way so do you agree with my five
picks to be on all-stars 5 which Queens
would you like to see on the season
which Queen deserves redemption from her
season let me know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe to ET
Canada's ep
[Music]